wow why has nobody mentioned this yet we
just got a bunch of new iPhones but
today we're gonna be focusing on the
brand new 14 pro Max and comparing to
the 13 Pro Max and cover all of the
differences that the early reviewers
didn't talk about such as the display
differences and dimming the speaker
differences graphics performance and
throttling as well as the always-on
display the new Dynamic Island and much
more now what I'm really curious about
is the new space black color that we
have right here people have been kind of
complaining online that it's not dark
enough and our 13 Pro Max is the
graphite color so we are going to see
how much of a difference it makes and
first impressions in this lighting my
goodness it looks almost identical
evidence I don't know what it looks like
for you there
let's pull it out man online and some
photos it looked a lot different uh okay
right here it looks darker right here
looks identical you know what I'm kind
of disappointed now looking at the frame
yes the space black one is a lot darker
pretty much at every angle so that's a
positive the camera bump does look
darker and the rings around the lenses
are pure black so overall it is a darker
aesthetic now one thing you probably
notice is just how big that camera bump
is it seems like it's getting larger
every year and people complained about
the 13 wobbling a lot which it
definitely did now the 14 let's check
this one out oh my goodness look at how
much that moves right there that is
crazy that's because these things stick
out a ton because of the new larger
sensors that require larger lenses and
the cameras are supposed to have gotten
a lot better this year now we always do
this comparison with the past two
generations to see how much of an
upgrade is it really so if you guys want
to see that it's super informative we
cover all of the details make sure sure
you guys click that subscribe button
down below and with that I want to thank
you guys for 1 million subscribers for
all of your support uh for Vadim
Angelica and I running this channel we
greatly appreciate it it's been an honor
to finally receive this plaque and
subscribe if you guys want to help us
reach our new goal and continue to grow
the power button has been moved down a
little bit this year which is great for
reachability and then I also notice that
the 5G antenna is quite a bit larger
this year so I'm really curious if they
did put in a new 5G chip it looks like
we are going to have to do a 5G speed
test later in this video but on the
other side it looks like the volume
switches actually were raised a bit
which is weird and the same thing with
our mute switch with that you probably
also noticed that we have no more Sim
slots that's because the four teams in
the US are all esim and some people
actually did not buy an iPhone 14
because of this they had to buy a 13 Pro
because they carry it doesn't support it
so that's a bummer now unfortunately
Apple did not give us USB type c so we
are still stuck with lighting but on the
plus side you don't actually have to use
it with moft SNAP stand power set now
I've been buying moth products for years
we've been recommending them and this
power bank has some really unique
features first off it uses USB type-c
and they put the port on the side which
means you can plug it in while you're
using the stand and it charges both the
battery and your phone while other
devices wouldn't allow you to do this
now with that you can have it standing
horizontally if you're watching videos
now this is designed for ultimate
modularity so I could take my phone off
and the stand separates as well so I
could be charging my earpods while using
the stand separately to watch videos and
of course this is not only a stand it is
by far my favorite wallet so holds three
cards at the same time this set works
great as a a bedside charger when you
come home and when you're ready to go
out you can choose and have ultimate
versatility than what you need if it's
just the wallet for today or if you want
the extra power with the power bank and
then pop on your wallet with that the
battery has a strong magnetic hold but
if you get moth's snap case this thing
has absolutely insane magnets personally
I really love how Sleek this battery is
and the fact that it has this vegan
leather so it has a really nice look and
feel to it go ahead and check it out on
our partner moff's website using the
links in the video description and Now
setting this thing up we have face ID
let's get started and look at that right
there we already have the dynamic Island
animation that looks super cool now the
bezels did get slightly Slimmer but it's
not as big of a difference as I expected
but that Notch switching over to the
dynamic Island definitely looks cleaner
and more minimal than having it stick
out there now with that that speaker
Grille it also is three times smaller
it's barely noticeable next to the frame
there and let's go ahead and check out
that Dynamic Island and everything you
could do of course the notch just gets
in the way where now this is actually a
legitimate feature let's start this
timer and then I'm going to close this
Down Bam right there that Dynamic Island
got larger I see the time at all times
which is wonderful I can press and hold
and then bam I have some controls right
there let's open up Apple music we're
playing this song and I'm gonna swipe up
bam it just added that right in split it
up to the pill and the cutout I'm gonna
press and hold here I see the song have
all my controls and then at the same
time I could still access my timer bam
it disappeared and now we're playing the
song and it's crazy how fluid everything
is the animations are top notch I mean
uh top Island and pretty much everybody
else agrees that this is just so cool
taking a downside and making it a
feature with that we also have some
major display differences that people
didn't talk about but first I'm curious
about the speakers do they get any
better or worse because of the ultra
slim earpiece speaker let's go ahead and
take a listen
[Music]
[Music]
all right wow why has nobody mentioned
this yet that was incredible not only is
it louder dramatically louder everything
sounds better I actually listened to it
side by side going back and forth and
thinking maybe they had to make the base
worse to make the highs have a lot more
clarity no it sounds better maybe the
myths know the mid sound better and the
highs they have a lot more clarity and
it's not just extra sharpness they
actually sound softer than with a 13 Pro
Max but with more clarity there's none
of that weird kind of like uh staticky
high pitched in the highs in order to
make them louder it's incredible the
whole Sound Stage sounds better sounds
more dynamic between the different
instruments I was not expecting this at
all so you know what let me open up a
super tough track this is a rock track
with a ton of different instruments and
vocals so let's take a listen
[Applause]
now we never
never
let
dang guys I don't know how much of it
you can hear through our mic through
YouTube compression but the separation
is a lot better there's another guitar
that you can hear which gets just mushed
together with everything on the older
iPhone the vocals stand out more uh the
drums I mean this is a big big
Improvement so if you like watching
movies listening music on your phone
that's a nice upgrade getting back to
the displays the first thing I noticed
is that the 14 pro Max has a warmer
display both a true tone on and with
that the viewing angles are quite a bit
better as well so it's a whole new OLED
panel maxing out the manual brightness
on both they look very close maybe
slightly brighter on the 14 pro Max now
going outside and enabling auto
brightness for that 2000 Peak that Apple
advertise we definitely saw it kick up
and get much brighter than the 13 Pro
Max the results were noticeable and that
is going to be really nice when you're
outside in the sun it's gonna really pop
now coming inside again and checking out
HDR Apple says can hit 1600 nits now
instead of the 13 Pro Max's previous
1200 so let's go ahead and take a look
right out of the gate I'm seeing a
little bit more brightness with the 14
pro Max and a little bit more contrast
and saturation now the difference isn't
huge you would think from 1200 to 1600
would be massive maybe some of these
brights aren't that bright that's what's
required uh but overall you definitely
do see it and combined with the outdoor
brightness coming up there you go that's
popping a little bit more it definitely
is a nice Improvement in the screen and
that also leads us right into the other
amazing feature that really stands out
the new always on display with the 14
Pros as soon as you shut it off it dims
down the color tones remain but it gets
a lot dimmer instead of shutting off
that is so nice and their implementation
of this always on display is much better
than the competition and now let's get
into performance one thing that nobody
really talks about is the disc speed
I'm gonna go ahead and run this wow that
is really fast now on the right speed
the difference is only 13 with the same
uh storages but the read is 70 percent
faster and that is when this phone was
uh without the storage filled up so that
is a pretty dramatic difference and we
also tested uh different capacities
there's no difference between 256 and
512 which is also great so you're
definitely getting faster storage as far
as CPU performance the 14 Pros are the
only ones that get the new a16 whereas
the 14s get the processor that's in the
13 pro and pro Max so looking at the
actual specs here uh we have a slightly
higher frequency but our Ram stayed the
same let's go ahead and run our CPU test
and see how much faster it is maybe the
ram being faster is going to make a
difference all right we have our results
and it's okay we have 13 faster as far
as single core and 12 faster as far as
multi-core score now both these are
scoring slightly less than what we've
seen before but you know that's an
incremental upgrade of course it's for
an animator so probably we have some
advantages as far as battery life but I
have another thing to show you guys that
nobody has shown you yet none of the
reviewers talked about this this is our
14 pro not the pro Max and I ran
geekbench here as well and this is crazy
we have a score of
4844 in terms of multi-core practically
identical as the 13 Pro Max and the 13
Pro meaning if you are gonna buy this
regular size 14 pro the performance is
not much better at all and if you want
the full performance you have to get the
pro Max because apple is just giving it
higher clock speeds because of its
better cooling capability and larger
chassis Apple didn't mention it they
should have reviewers didn't mention it
and here you go at maxc we're showing
this off and now let's go ahead and
check out the graphics performance with
our compute Benchmark and here it is we
have a difference of seven percent so
even worse than on the CPU side I missed
the days when we were having these 40
jumps these massive ones so this is
barely any different now how did the
regular 14 pro hold up man look at that
the score is actually higher than the 14
pro Max so unlike the CPU Apple's not
capping the performance of the graphics
they want to make sure that if you're
gaming you still get good performance so
that is a positive but with that are we
gonna have to be dealing with the screen
dimming issues that we had with the 13s
let's go ahead and check it out I have
antutu opened up right here and we got
the phone set bright so we're gonna go
ahead and start running this is a test
that really pushes the phones and it
tests out the graphics performance and
we definitely got dimming before of
course in other regular games we got
dimming and if you're using mobile
cellular data as well it was just very
frustrating in the past oh right there
you guys see the iPhone 13 dimming right
away at the start right there at the end
of the first test you guys see that the
14 pro is definitely brighter the tests
are loading up faster because of that
storage speed oh did you guys see that
oh no Vadim do you saw that dim ah come
on Apple put in new thermal graphite
material and now okay the 13 just dimmed
even more I mean this is a tough test
but I did not expect the 14 pro to dim
that fast I was hoping it with dim at
all this is one of our biggest
annoyances with the previous ones yeah
and it looks like it has not been fixed
at least here when it's loading up the
next test the 14 pro Max is definitely
brighter but let's see what keeps
happening here in this next test I mean
one thing I'm noticing is that the 14
pro Max is much smoother and we still
have some drop frames it's a tough test
but this one maybe it's slowing down
because of the heat you guys see the
brightness differences the 14 pro Max is
definitely brighter right now I think
what's happening is that the 13 Pro Max
keeps dimming more and more so while the
14 pro Max is staying a bit more
consistent busting out the thermal
camera I want to see the heat
differences we definitely have a bigger
hot spot on the 14 pro Max at 4142
degrees Celsius the 13 Pro Max also same
temperatures just less spread which that
is actually a good thing that the 14 pro
Max has taken at heat and spreading it
out instead of keeping it concentrated
where it's going to slow down the
performance of the graphics and and
caused the screen to dim more and here
you see yes this does Dim when that is
unfortunate it sucks it's not fixed but
it is a lot better so if you guys want
to see a more in-depth gaming test have
a team test out both with a variety of
games for a longer period of time make
sure you guys click that subscribe
button down below and here are the
scores overall we have a difference of
13 as far as a CPU we have a 15
difference so it's actually bigger than
we had in geekbench GPU has a five
percent difference that's a little bit
smaller that might be because both of
them did have to slow down uh their
Graphics we had the screen dimming
kicking in on both memory we have a big
difference we showed that off previously
and the ux the you the smoothness uh for
your scrolling all that kind of stuff
not much of a difference overall so what
we did find is that yes it does still
dim it does suck that that it does but
it's not as big of an issue as we had
previously and now let's go ahead and
test out out the 5G speeds I swapped out
that space black one for my gold because
I have the Sim enabled and then we're
going across two sims uh let's open this
up and see what we get now initially it
looks like we're getting a worse bar
than the older 13 Pro Max here the
results I ran these separately and it
looks like as far as download we have
slightly faster but as far as upload it
is quite a bit slower almost half the
speed now we are indoors in a concrete
building with 5G enabled the pars are
very low but the download speeds are
very good now what I want to do is go
into the settings and switch over to LTE
instead of 5G on not everybody has 5G
and let's see what we get dang guys look
at that we have 18.8 download and 2 for
upload compared to 90 and almost eight
so if you don't have 5G and you're in
inside of a building the new iPhone 14
pro antenna and cellular chip does a way
better job with the same amount of Lte
bars and now let's go ahead and head
outside I tested them separately to make
sure it's fair and look we have a 125
download on the 13 Pro compared to 245.
that's a huge difference as far as the
upload we have 30 compared to 46. now
the upload is way better than it was
inside but the download is actually
slower which is quite odd so I just
wonder if you're inside and you have no
signal maybe the antenna puts a boost
you know use a lot more power but
outside doesn't need to and just
optimizing for Speed so overall yes the
14 pro Max does have much faster
cellular speeds and now let's talk about
the cameras probably one of the biggest
reasons why people are going to be
upgrading on the front we finally have a
camera that has autofocus so let's see
if there's a difference I'm going to
bring this closer than normal take a
shot you guys go ahead and let me know
what you think to me it definitely looks
sharper with the new one I also see a
difference in HDR we have a lot more pop
in the highlights so that definitely
looks nicer now with the rear cameras we
have that 48 megapixel camera that will
over sample to 12 megapixels so let me
go outside and I'm going to take a
couple shots I'll also get one with a
three times telephoto that hasn't
changed but I want to know how much of a
difference does software make so here's
our first shot with the wide camera this
is just out of the box shooting I want
to see do we see any more detail and
honestly I don't really see it this
one's actually a little bit darker uh
might have a little bit more compression
noise here in the actual building let's
go over to the trees honestly I think
the old shot looks better in this
perfect kind of lighting scenario with a
lot of HDR now I went into the settings
to enable Pro raw because I want to test
out the full 48 megapixel and it
actually gives you the option to down
sample those files but this is the full
huge file right here let's go ahead and
zoom into this water tower and my
goodness I mean look at that detailed
difference we have this waxy kind of
washed out mess compared to all of that
detail right there yeah if you want the
most detail if you're gonna be cropping
in you want to enable that now I also
took a 15x and right in the gate you
can't tell that much of a difference but
if we crop in it's definitely better
with the new processing on the 14 pro
here's a portrait shot with the new 2x
crop mode from the main sensor compared
to the full size shot it's definitely
nice to have that extra reach but not
punch in too much where before you would
have to crop in on the regular shot or
get closer and take a shot like this
that's distorted now of course we also
have video differences we have the ultra
wide the low light light modes so we are
going to be doing a detailed comparison
where I'm going to test out the 14 pro
Max 13 Pro Max in 12 Pro Max and show
you all of the differences in photo and
video so you guys can see for yourselves
if it's worth upgrading if you guys want
to see that click that subscribe button
above overall let us know are you happy
with this new phone did anything
surprise you check out one of those
great videos over there that's been Max
and I'll see you in the next video
[Music]
all right